- Like so many women have come up to you
and gone,
I'm so a Penelope.
- So a Penelope.
Yeah, yeah
- And it's so sweet.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For years you used to get
script where you're like
she's this guy's girlfriend and you go
what woman that you know is
just this guy's girlfriend.
That's not a thing.
- Yeah.
- You know?
We're all fully rounded
human beings on this show
like makes on our character,
like do unlikable things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, but like you
have to allow it thing.
- You do unlikeable things.
- Exactly.
I always make the joke.
I always say like, no
one watched breaking bad
and they're like, let's make Walter Wright
like a little softer.
So he is like a little
more, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Like, he's just not very relatable.
We don't like root for him, but like.
- He's never relatable.
Could you please like tone it down.
- In a nice little jumper?
That's a bit more, you know?
Yeah.
We wouldn't, we would never do that.
(Kelly laughs)
We would never do that.
Yeah.
Oh my God, that was the greatest analogy.